on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant à moscou thuan claireaux
bonjour antoine donc beaucoup de
réactions internationales
après l'arrestation d' alexeï navalni
hier soir une réaction également du
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
oui tout à fait sergueï lavrov à
l'occasion de sa conférence de presse
annuelle est revenu à plusieurs reprises
sur la sphère navalni à la lumière donc
des événements d'hier
pour le ministre russe tout le bruit à
l'international autour de cette affaire
n'a pas lieu d'être et ne sert qu'à
détourner l'attention du public des
problèmes internes des pays en question
je vous propose d'écouter sa réaction
dans le cas de navalni il y ait une
résonance internationale qui je pense
est artificielle et qui est tout à fait
injustifiée tout ce qui se produit ici
au tour de na vallier de son retour son
arrestation
cela relève de décisions des services de
justice et de police
il ya un service fédéral qui est celui
de l'exécution des peines qui a énoncé à
sa trempe de faits concrets et qui a
expliqué pourquoi c'est
réclamations à son égard ont été
formulées donc il n'ya pas de
déclarations possibles du ministère des
affaires étrangères ici il ya simplement
le respect des lois de la fédération de
russie
il n'en reste pas moins que
l'arrestation de l'opposant russe
quasiment à sa descente de l'avion a
suscité de nombreux commentaires
indignés
parmi les responsables politiques
occidentaux en voici quelques exemples
la france a pris connaissance avec une
très forte préoccupation de
l'arrestation en russie de monsieur
alexeï navalni elle suit avec ses
partenaires européens sa situation avec
la plus grande vigilance et appellent à
sa libération immédiate
profondément troublé par la décision de
la russie d'arrêter alexeï navalni les
dirigeants politiques confiant ne
craignent pas les voies concurrentes ni
ne voient la nécessité de commettre des
violences ou de détenir à tort des
opposants politiques
je condamne la détention d'alexei de
navalni par les autorités russes
ils doivent le libérer immédiatement et
assurer sa sécurité
la détention d'opposants politiques va à
l'encontre des engagements
internationaux de la russie après son
rétablissement alexeï navalni a pris la
décision consciente de retourner en
russie parce qu'ils y voient sa maison
personnelle et politique le fait qu'il a
été arrêté par les autorités russes dès
son arrivée est totalement
incompréhensible
il est consternant alexeï navalni
victime d'un crime méprisable est
étaient détenus par les autorités russes
il doit être immédiatement libérés
plutôt que de persécuter monsieur
navalni la russie devrait expliquer
comment une arme chimique a été utilisée
sur le sol russe elle la détention d'
alexeï navalni à son arrivée à moscou
est inacceptable j'appelle les autorités
russes à le libérer immédiatement
alors le principal intéressé s'est lui
aussi exprimé dans une vidéo relayée par
sa porte parole
il s'insurge contre le traitement
judiciaire qui lui est réservé en
dénonçant l'illégalité de la procédure
écoutez j'ai vu beaucoup de parodies de
justice en russie
il semble que le grand
père dans son bunker a tellement peur
qu'on déchire et qu'on jette le code de
procédure pénale à la poubelle ce qui se
passe ici est tout simplement impossible
c'est l'illégalité la plus totale
maîtrise type une inconnue à l'heure
actuelle alexeï navalni est donc
toujours en détention
a priori jusqu'à une audience pour
l'instant fixée au 29 janvier un juge
devra alors statué sur la violation de
son contrôle judiciaire l'opposant russe
devait en effet respecter les conditions
d'une période probatoire qui courait
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 alors
qu'il terminait sa convalescence en
allemagne
il n'avait pu 2 fait répondre aux
obligations de son contrôle judiciaire
merci beaucoup antoine perreault pour
toutes ces précisions direct depuis
moscou fin